in this reality there are objects
without life there are plants that have
life but no ability to actively
participate in it there are animals with
life that they can actively participate
in but no awareness of the fact that
they are doing so in this reality I have
life I am able to actively participate
in it and I am aware that I am doing so
unlike anything else ever known in the
history of life on this planet I have
the ability to understand that I have
life on this planet as a human I can
know and appreciate that I am the
profound result of millions of years of
life's evolutionary effort to perceive
itself with every breath I can know that
I am fueled by an abundant resource of a
gas we call oxygen which somehow has the
perfect molecular structure to meet the
needs of my body and to keep me alive I
can know that I can understand complex
language and enjoy music out of the
vibrations that rattle the instrument
that is my eardrum I can know that I can
see light bounce off of random
collections of dense matter and
recognize beauty I can know that through
the thousands of little stimuli on my
tongue I can distinguish and savor the
different flavors are the things that
are used to nourish my body
and I can know that I can reach out and
touch the world fully aware that I am
touching a piece of a giant rock
floating through an infinite universe
far more than just being able to do any
of these things what is most amazing is
that I can know that I can do these
things I can understand the brilliantly
complex relationship between myself and
the life I inhabit I can understand that
I was given the rare and surreal
opportunity to experience this life as a
human and for that I can be thanked
[Music]
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this videos
please give it a thumbs up share your
thoughts in the comments below and if
you are not already be sure to subscribe
to our channel we are constantly coming
out with new videos to help you
experience life with clarity and Wonder